foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
folks welcome to the Dark Horse podcast
live stream number 185 I am Dr Brett
Weinstein I'm sitting with Dr Heather
Hein who is clearly in need of a shirt
change a shirt change so apparently we
Clash which I don't acknowledge is a
thing I think a person can Clash within
what they're wearing but two people
shouldn't be clashing but I I am color
deficient not only do we Clash but I
clash with the set Oh no you're double
um out of sorts well maybe we'll just
lean into it it's it's the punk version
of Dark Horse
all right right if they don't like it
that's on them now in magenta all right
now we got a little slice of dog behind
us by the way if you're just listening
to the audio version we don't Clash
we're in fact perfectly color
coordinated and well adjusted to the
chromatism of the set
August
August 2023 and
we'll talk some about kobit today
because it persists in our world and in
its uh in the way that the world dealt
with it and how those repercussions
continue to
um continue to persist yes it's true we
are going to uh make a slight departure
from our usual mode we are going to
discuss covet in our usual mode but I am
also going to try out a new mode of
making points that is somewhat more
shall we say narrative
we might even say it's no
what were you gonna say
no I think I think I I think I should
say it after you do your thing okay if
it fits very good all right well let's
let's not forget to do that and we may
uh we may talk a little bit about music
as well all right uh at the end here uh
okay so
um
We're not gonna do a q a today so it's
it's just just this and we're going to
tell you all about the other ways to to
find us at the end but as usual we do
start out the top of the hour with our
with three ad sponsors whom we have
carefully chosen uh and vetted and who
we actually truly vouch for this week
it's seed biome and paleo Valley without
further Ado Brett you are up first I am
up first so I don't even have a model to
go on but I'm just gonna I'm gonna read
what's on there I mean I did give you a
script yeah but the Reading part is not
as easy for some of us okay here we go
our first sponsor this week is seed a
probiotic that really works if you've
tried probiotics before and got nothing
out of it try seed it's designed
differently from other probiotics it's
designed better it actually works hey
this is going all right yes your gut and
your immune system work together
coordinating your body's response to the
world both around and within you seed
helps improve the health of your gut
micro the health of your gut microbiome
that's the way that sentence reads which
means that it supports you becoming
healthier overall our resident gut
microbes directly impact the development
and function of the immune system even
before we're born microbes inform your
immune system teaching our body how to
distinguish between benign substances
and pathogenic antigens that is
substances that our body doesn't
recognize as its own
you can support your gut immune axis in
a variety of ways including by
prioritizing sleep new research suggests
that the gut microbiome has its own
circadian clock and that changes your
normal rhythms and that changes to your
normal rhythms that's what this sentence
says can disrupt your microbes and the
important functions they perform
prioritizing regular sleep can thus help
keep your gut immune axis healthy the
Axis of Awesome
you can also support your gut immune
axis by taking seeds DS Dash zero one
daily synbiotic seed is a plant-based
Prebiotic and probiotic with 24 strains
that have been clinically or
scientifically studied for their
benefits 16 of those 24 strains are
specifically geared towards Digestive
Health as you would expect from a
probiotic and four of the 24 probiotic
strains are known to promote healthy
skin your skin like your gut has its own
microbiome seed supports both gut and
skin health
seed is free from 14 major classes of
antigens including but not limited to
sugar animal products soy gluten peanuts
glyphosate Dairy shellfish and corn and
seed is basically double hauled with its
capsule in capsule design it is
engineered to maintain viability through
your digestive tract until it reaches
your colon where you want it and the
same design makes it resistant to oxygen
moisture and heat meaning that no
Refrigeration is necessary
seeds daily symbionic supports gut skin
and heart health and micronutrient
synthesis we have heard from several
people who have used seed and Report
improvements to their digestive function
in 24 to 48 hours so start a new healthy
habit today visit seed.com Darkhorse and
use the code Darkhorse to redeem 25 off
your first month of seeds ds01 daily
symbiotic that's seed.com Darkhorse and
use the code Darkhorse at checkout
our second sponsor this week is biome
maker of knobs and obs
knobs is a new kind of dentifrus down to
Frisk being anything you use to clean
your teeth toothpaste or powders or
knobs knobs are fantastic biome that's
biom without the e on the end is focused
on transparency safety and efficacy and
knobs is a truly fantastic product let's
talk fluoride fluoride is the
anti-cavity ingredient in most
toothpastes that you already know about
but as we discuss in our book The
fluoride in drinking water and
toothpaste is not a molecular form that
is found in nature or that has ever been
part of our diet and Evermore research
is pointing to neurotoxicity from
fluoride exposure especially in children
knobs from biome does not contain
fluoride but unlike comparative products
knobs does include a different and far
better remineralizing agent that's
hydroxyapatite hydroxyapatite is the
main component of the enamel in your
teeth and it is in your bones as well it
is as effective as fluoride and
remineralizing teeth without the
toxicity
hydroxyapatite doesn't merely stop
cavities from forming it can even arrest
tooth decay once it's underway knobs
also has no abrasives like charcoal or
baking soda and no sulfates parabens
phthalates or microplastics no BS it's
right there in the name
furthermore knobs comes in the form of
dehydrated tablets which allows them to
be shelf stable without any
preservatives take a tablet chew it a
few times and brush as normal your teeth
are going to feel fantastically clean
because they are also unlike with
toothpaste TSA has no interest in knobs
because they're tablets so if you're
flying with knobs you don't risk losing
your dentiferous insecurity so check out
knobs at
www.betterbiome.com Darkhorse that's
biome without the e once again that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-b-i-o-m.com Darkhorse
listeners can enjoy 15 off their first
one a month supply of knobs so go to
betterbiome.com darkhorsenow to discover
a great new way to clean your teeth
good stuff it's really good I really I
really the more I use it the more I feel
like it is the right way to be doing
this and all of those years of uh paste
it falls off your toothbrush and every
other dignity is just it's you know
you've mentioned this before and I love
the knobs but the uh I I don't know
maybe it's a sex thing but I could count
on the fingers of one hand that I've had
toothpaste fall off my toothbrush that's
because you're doing it wrong
this is just a problem that you invoke
every now and again like really I mean
it may be that it doesn't happen as
often as I think it does but it's
traumatic every time I'm so maddening
because you drop it like on the dog or
something toothpaste is more expensive
than you would think right it's just I
know exactly there are fewer in a tube
and it's more expensive and so you lose
one so you like the dosage the dosing of
the knobs as well well the dosing of the
knobs is good but the point is when you
lose the risk of pouring foreign
worth of toothpaste into the sink then
what do you do because only the very
bottom part is sullied but you really
wouldn't want to I mean it just
let's put it this way chewing up the
tablet and then brushing your teeth
makes so much more sense
I have had my toothpaste ball off of
many times I'm not concerned what
happens that much
all right but still knobs is great and
if this is a problem for you that is
toothpaste falling off your toothbrush
knob solves that problem uh just you
know chew the knobs of your mouth closed
mmm good point
in general with your mouth closed it's
advisable okay our third sponsor our
final sponsor this week is Paleo Valley
paleo Valley makes a huge range of
products we talked about the beef sticks
last week and everything we've tried
from them has been terrific today I want
to tell you about their superfood golden
milk
golden milk is also known as turmeric
milk it's delicious nutritious hot drink
rich in turmeric usually made in a base
of either milk or coconut milk your
choice
turmeric is a flowering plant in the
ginger family and grows across much of
tropical Asia just with ginger the
rhizome of turmeric has been used
culinarily and medicinally across
cultures for a very long time
modern research backs up ancient
Traditions isn't that great when that
happens and it often is and we now know
that turmeric is an antioxidant and
anti-inflammatory among many other
beneficial mechanisms of action and a
particularly delicious way to get
turmeric in your diet is through golden
milk if you cook you know that you can
use turmeric as a spice that you add to
your food but you don't end up adding
that much it's it's it's a little much
whereas in Golden milk you can get a
pretty high dose and it's delicious
enter paleo Valley's superfood golden
milk paleo Valley's delicious product
has turmeric of course but also Ginger
again a a close relative cinnamon black
pepper coconut milk powder a little bit
of monk fruit to add sweetness and
several species of mushrooms as well not
standard in Golden milk lion's mane
reishi shiitake and cordyceps it's
gluten-free grain free soy free non-GMO
and it's delicious
paleo Valley doesn't cut Corners they
Source only the highest quality
ingredients and they use whole
ingredients unlike many competitive
products their superfood golden milk for
instance has only has whole turmeric not
just curcumin which is a component of
turmeric which is often uh the uh the
like supplement that you would buy and
also whole certified organic mushrooms
not just the Mycelia golden milk is
understood to help reduce inflammation
enhance cognitive function support
immune function improve digestion and
increase endurance among other things
paleo Valley is passionate not only
about human health but environmental
restoration and Animal Welfare as well
and they're a family-owned company
tripelio valleys superfood golden milk
today you will be so glad that you did
head over to paleoballey.com Darkhorse
for 15 off your first order yeah the
golden melt is very nice before bed if
you're looking for a little something
sometimes tea isn't the right thing I
apologize to our British listeners but
sometimes tea isn't the right thing and
the golden milk is uh super nice
I'm gonna go a step further
I find that usually tea is not oh my God
are you trying to drive off our British
listeners yeah t just you know I mean
we're our own country for a reason guys
and uh
actually trying to revive the Boston Tea
Party on all right well yeah but I I I
rarely reach for tea and uh and golden
the Golden milk I have really enjoyed
and I hadn't made it at home before I've
ordered it in a few places where I've
seen it on the menu and and loved it um
but paleo Valley superfood gold milk is
um is a terrific product yeah really
great and you can and you can as as
delicious in um actual milk or coconut
milk or some other milk alternative if
Dairy doesn't suit you which it doesn't
suit a lot of people indeed all right
all right here we are whoa here we are a
Confluence a a Confluence so a
Confluence born of influence I'm not
sure who influenced him but no I don't
either uh you've got a bunch of things
that you want to talk about today and
they're all kind of related uh it wasn't
clear to me what order they might
um most beneficially go and so I'm going
to let you take the lead here sure okay
let's start with
um John Campbell who
um nice I see another Confluence John
Campbell who reported on a new study
Zach do you want to show the study I
also have it here all right oh the study
yeah the um
you can show my screen because I've
actually got the full article
um okay so sex specific differences in
myocardial injury incidents after
covid-19 mRNA 1273 booster vaccination
now the interesting thing about this
study is instead of looking at people
who showed up in a medical setting
complaining of issues that then turned
out to be myocarditis or pericarditis
what they did is they simply censused
the blood of people who took a booster
for troponins which are a marker of
cellular damage in the heart
um so in other words this is a test in
some sense of what we've talked about
previously on the podcast which is if
you're seeing all of these cases of
myocarditis how many cases are you not
seeing because they didn't reach a point
where the person sought medical help for
them right they had some pain they
misunderstood what it was they never
showed up in a doctor's office which is
still potentially life reducing right
myocarditis is a serious condition and
uh it is profoundly associated with
shortened lifespan
so it is good to know how many of these
subclinical cases there are and in this
study as reported by you want to read
what you got there yeah this is just
from the abstract and I'll skip the
statistical uh specificity but among 100
among 777 participants median age 37
years
69.5 percent of women
among 777 participants median age 37
69.5 women that's just right that's a
sample uh four right sorry uh 40
participants had elevated hsct T
concentration on day three and and we're
on a 1273 vaccine Associated myocardial
injury was adjudicated in 22
participants and one of the interesting
things that come out of this is not just
the remarkably High rate of uh of heart
injury uh associated with the boosters
uh it was about 1 in 35 but that as I
say here in the abstract 20 cases
occurred in women 3.7 percent and two in
men 0.8 percent uh and these are you
know mild and only temporary so they're
they're referring to these as transient
which is why presumably they haven't
been caught previously uh but that it's
a it's a much higher higher rate in
women uh than in men which is of course
the opposite direction of the less
transient injury transient injury that
we've been hearing about more and you
know of course what is part of what is
raised here is uh what does it mean that
it is transient right the indicator is
transient is true but that doesn't mean
that there aren't lasting effects right
and in fact
as I have pointed out again and again
the heart is a very special tissue in
which damage is it produces a scar
rather than a proper repair even in
tissues where you have a proper repair
there's a limit in almost all tissues
there are a couple of exceptions but in
almost all tissues there is a limit to
how much repair you can do in a lifetime
so even if you have a repair in which a
loss of function is not detectable what
these things do is they Advance the
Aging of those tissues so that you can
you know you get a certain number of
those repairs in life
and if you keep breaking the same thing
you exhaust them early right or you know
in my case I lost teeth because an
orthodontist moved my teeth too rapidly
and he burned up my lifetime capacity
for repair in jaw tissue and so anyway
the jaw tissue has a higher capacity for
repair than your heart does vastly
vastly higher and it has a built-in
system for dealing with minor motions of
teeth because your skull shape changes
over a lifetime but put that aside the
heart is one of a small number of
tissues that has essentially no capacity
for proper repair that is to say cells
do not get replaced in kind what they
get replaced with is scar tissue that
allows the heart to continue to function
but you don't regain the capacity of the
fully functional heart that you damaged
so the expectation is these troponins
are a useful marker you ever wonder how
if you have something that seems to be a
heart attack and uh you recover within a
couple of days they can test you and see
whether you did have a heart attack it's
markers like this that they use so
anyway the fact that these markers show
up suggests damage to the heart the idea
that the markers are transient as you
point out doesn't mean that the damage
is transient and all of it is pretty
scary because myocarditis is
demonstrated to be a life shortening
condition
um so anyway one does have the sense
that the paper was written to emphasize
the transientness you know here's an
interesting finding but maybe it uh you
know I don't I I didn't actually get
that I've uh I've skimmed the paper and
I did not get the sense that they were
um trying to emphasize the transientness
but trying to be very careful about uh
saying the the as you say the markers
that we used were transient right but in
any case the idea that if you test
people who got
um this shot
without them having to show up reporting
a complaint and you find a 1 in 35 rate
and you know it's not a huge sample size
but nonetheless one in 35 is a huge
number of people to have a heart injury
from a vaccine that was given where
almost all of the people it was given to
would have recovered from covid on its
own didn't need a shot to protect them
and what's more the shot didn't protect
them the shot did not prevent
transmission or contraction and it even
now seems to make contraction of the
disease more likely if you get enough of
these things so the whole thing is is an
incredible debacle it raises questions
for me of course about what what this
research would look like in people after
getting their their first breaks the
first vaccine because this is of course
and people already vaccinated Hospital
workers already vaccinated going in for
their boosters so you know is is this a
higher rate than we would see after a
first or second vaccine my guess is yes
um that there there's cumulative damage
Associated that these that these markers
May persist for longer or come on uh in
more people the more the more these
shots people get but I don't I haven't
seen that research so I don't know well
it depends
sorry I should say I haven't seen that
research because I don't think it's been
done it depends radically on the
mechanism of action of the damage and
this is we're going to get a little
deeper into this in the next little
section but you know depending uh
Mark Gerardo I think is his last name
Advanced what I think is a high quality
Theory Mark or high quality hypothesis
Mark
um believes it is the reason for the
damage I believe it is a contributor but
his point was he calls it bolus Theory
and the idea is that a bolus dose that
gets into your bloodstream by virtue of
the needle not having been aspirated and
occasionally hitting a vein results in a
large amount of this mRNA coded in lipid
nanoparticle flooding tissues of the
body and when a big dose of it hits the
heart
you get the equivalent of an internal
burn right because those cells are taken
up they're then killed by the immune
system this is the thing I've been
arguing that this thing properly
transfects cells it wasn't supposed to
transfect those cells get destroyed by
the immune system and if that's in your
heart it's a disaster that does not
require it to be a bolus dose that can
be any dose any cell that gets
transfected in your heart will then be
attacked by your immune system but
um but in any case if it's the bolus
dose issue so that each time you get one
of these shots and the needle is not
aspirated you're running the risk of a
bolus dose then the basic point is
you're it's a lottery each time and so
you wouldn't necessarily expect a big
difference between the first shot the
second shot the third shot is just that
each time the chances that the needle
lands in the vein would predispose you
to an injury and the point is oh God
that's really scary if it's 1 in 35 each
time then three shots in you're 3 and
35. so it's a distinction between
um cumulative versus everyone is an
independent uh crapshoot rather like the
risk from say some of the
um radioactive particles uh that have
that may be uh in fish from Fukushima
yeah exactly exactly
um so in any case the the large
background rate of a this is not a minor
issue and you would have damage even if
the thing worked correctly but the
damage would be in a tissue where you
could afford it if the thing worked
according to its design the point at
which it escapes your your deltoid and
is circulating in the body it's a
crapshoot in that regard too and the
fact is
again we're dealing with 1 in 35 which
is an unacceptably large rate but now
imagine that you know they're not
looking at markers for damage to your
kidneys
right um but the you know the the flip
side the
um hopeful side of the bolus hypothesis
uh is that if you weren't affected then
you're scot-free
right like if if that is the excuse me
the mechanism of damage the mechanism of
action for damage
um and there is actually no reason to
expect that there's only one but if that
if that were the only or the by far
primary mechanism of action for damage
and uh you didn't get the damage uh
after a shot then uh you should you know
we we hear from people less now because
there's there's you know people are less
focused on on the vaccines and there are
fewer mandates and all of this now
um but I've heard from people who are
living in fear
um because they've been vaccinated and
are and are quite worried and I think
the you know the bolus hypothesis if it
is if it is true uh should should be
promoted to people uh as evidence that
you know what you you should nothing
that you have done should prompt you to
now live in fear of something that you
cannot change and uh if if you you know
if if you didn't and you seem to have
gotten away with it good for you well I
slightly differ with this because
the degree to which people were injured
a they have a right to know for many
reasons the fact that there is obvious
fraud they have a right to know so the
question is I know I would never suggest
they've never right to know okay but
the idea that you weren't harmed because
it was a bolus dose that does the harm
will cause people who maybe were harmed
not to pursue levels of damage that may
be less than they would have gotten in
the case of a bolus dose so there are
legal reasons that they need to continue
to be vigilant about this there was
fraud which means that the immunity I'm
talking about individuals living in fear
that at any moment they're going to kill
over I I you were talking about a very
different level and I believe that
you're making it sound like I think that
people should just move forward and like
not look back and you know not think
about
um the incredibly diabolical things that
were done to all of us as a society and
many individuals now you know that's not
true so don't don't straw man my
argument here really is this like I I
was speaking to individuals and you know
maybe you just haven't seen these these
messages but individuals who are scared
and having a hard time sort of moving
around in their own world because
they've become you know just as many
people and I think you know the the
other side of that was many people were
so scared of covid and so convinced by
the
by the journalistic malpractice and
public health malpractice that assured
them if they just got these vaccines and
if everyone around them did then they
would be safe they lived in fear of
those of us who didn't get them now that
was ridiculous that was absurd and there
was no truth in that whatsoever but
there are some number of people who are
scared walking around because they did
get vaccinated and fear that some you
know that they're basically a ticking
time bomb and I don't think that's
helpful
uh well I don't know what the right
answer is the fact is even I don't you
know I don't know what every time I get
on my bike and you know struggle up a
hill or something I'm grateful that I
don't have to worry about whether I'm
gonna push my heart to some limit that I
used to be able to reach that is now
beyond my capacity because of one of
these injuries so uh you know there's
that on the other hand if you more or
less seem to have gotten away with it
with the shot you don't have anything
that you detected should you proceed as
if nothing happened or should you be
aware that you may actually have had
some damage that was subclinical that
has important ramifications maybe it has
a five year time Horizon maybe you know
by the time you've gone five years and
not detected anything uh in terms of
reduced heart capacity at that point it
would be justified to assume that
nothing happened but
I don't know what the right answer is I
on the one hand I feel terrible for
people who are walking around Under This
Cloud
on the other hand there if it were me
and I was walking around under that
cloud I would want to think very
carefully through what it should alter
about how I behave and what I expect
um because as terrible as it would be to
think about that regularly not doing it
carries its own risks
um but anyway
1 in 35
detectable heart damage or a s single of
the third dose of a particular shot if
that number is either
cumulative or in some other way
compounding then we need to understand
what that pattern is further
if we're not checking for markers to
damage to other tissues as you point out
in the Fukushima fish example you don't
find what you're not looking for
the so now we have to be very precise
here
a good vaccine let's say a
um a attenuated virus-based vaccine
will cause some damaged tissues because
the immune system will Target the cells
that have been infected by this
attenuated virus
however it will not be the body-wide
crapshoot that the MRNA vaccines are
because whatever virus was attenuated
had a particular ecology where it was
focused on invading cells that were
useful to it and not focused on any
salad encounters so there will be a
limit to the amount of damage and
that was simply absent from the design
of the MRNA shots there is no targeting
whatsoever the targeting was entirely
about where it was injected and the fact
that we knew that it escaped from the
deltoid means the body is all open to
being transfected with this stuff and so
therefore
what can we say
unlike a normal vaccine there will be
damage across many tissues that damage
could be widely distributed and in many
tissues that will be unimportant right
you will not be able to measure a
difference doesn't mean no damage we
shouldn't think of it as no damage but
we should say undetectable in any
concentrated way
as as even
um
compelling traditional
vaccines would cause which is net
beneficial because
um well let's put it this way if you
take an attenuated virus vaccine it has
almost no reason to attack a cell in
your heart
because the heart is not a good place
from which to spread to other people so
the heart would be isolated from that
damage by virtue of The evolutionary
Ecology of the virus that was attenuated
because no such thing exists with the
MRNA platform what we have to say is
look this is going to transfect some
heart cells it's going to result in the
immune system attacking those heart
cells there are people for whom that's
just simply not a risk worth taking it's
lots of them
an mRNA
vaccine in quotes is inherently
indiscriminate because you've you've
abandoned The Selective pressure of the
original organism
virus
and of course with SARS Kobe 2 we have
that two times because you've already
abandoned the original selective
pressure of the original virus by
creating a Franken virus in a lab based
on an original virus so you've got some
selective environment that still the
public health authorities and the
researchers aren't being honest about
with regard to how this thing was
created in the first place and then
you've got a vaccine that is that is
only providing instructions to make the
spike protein and that will go anywhere
as opposed to an attenuated virus
vaccine which is still driven by its you
know unconscious all of this but it's
evolutionary its original evolutionary
pressure to get to tissues where it can
then spread to other in individuals
potential hosts yep so for two big
reasons we've got these these mRNA
so-called vaccines
that are more likely to do damage than a
traditional attenuated virus vaccine yes
and I would point out that the logic of
the attenuated virus vaccine is somewhat
sketchier with the adenovector dna-based
coveted vaccine but it's a lot closer
because they did borrow an existing
virus right it's not an attenuated virus
what
um the logic that says an attenuated
virus is limited by The ancestral
Ecology of the virus that was attenuated
this is you know the the dna-based
vaccine they borrowed a wholly different
virus right it's not SARS Kobe 2 right
so it is effectively an attenuated virus
but because there's new technology here
it is less it hasn't been fully stripped
of its evolutionary background right and
so the evolutionary background will have
it targeted on whatever cells that
ancestral virus that they've borrowed no
I don't know what you know what the
evolutionary Ecology of that of the
adenovirus I don't know um
of Nature and it did something and and
who knows in that something wasn't
spreading from host to host by targeting
heart cells right exactly the the point
is a virus has an interest in leaving
you intact in tissues where it is not
getting an advantage by replicating
because uh you spread it more if you're
is still up on your feet right it's not
like a
mosquito-borne uh pathogen where
knocking you flat on your back actually
serves the the pathogen the virus wants
you on your feet enough to spread it and
so that will apply to the Adeno virus
that the DNA vaccines are based on it
does not apply to the pseudovirus that
is effectively what the MRNA vaccines
are based on
Okay so
we've got some huge rate if we look only
at the heart we've got a huge rate of
subclinical injuries
from a particular inoculation of a shot
that people got many inoculations of and
we don't yet know the story of how those
inoculations compound so that is a
frightening and important picture as
John Campbell says if Regulators don't
take notice of this what the hell is
going on right how can they miss this
but anyway that's where that story
stands and and it's uh it's worth
thinking about
which then brings us to the next piece
of the puzzle which a conversation
caught my attention I haven't seen the
full conversation but it is Paul oft
talking to
Gad sad and Gad said so Paul offit is a
uh
I think of vaccine evangelist is the
only term that you know he's like a
hote's like character
um where he is such a passionate
advocate for this set of technologies
that he appears to miss the obvious
signs that there are dangers and
um and that caution needs to be exerted
cost-benefit analysis needs to be done
very carefully and by people who don't
have a conflict of interest and recently
Bobby Kennedy Jr has
uh taken Paul off it to task apparently
he had personal interactions with him in
which he brought things to off its
attention that should have raised off
its eyebrows about uh vaccine safety and
I believe the lack of placebo controls
and often disappeared and wouldn't
respond so anyway people can look into
what Bobby Kennedy has said but this
conversation with Gad said and Paul
offit had an interesting
exchange which I will show you we have a
tweet that contains it yeah is there a
problematic link between the covet
vaccine and heart inflammation
there certainly is a a causal link
between vaccination and myocarditis and
pericarditis no doubt about it uh the
the
um
it's unclear why I mean it may be as was
actually noticed in 2020 that SARS cov2
virus the spike protein mimics
um a one of the proteins on heart muscle
cells specifically the the heavy chain
of of of of actin so so if that's true
then while you're making an immune
response to the source could we do Spike
protein you're also inadvertently making
an immune response to your own heart
muscle
all right so uh the uh the attribution
was cut off on the screenshot there that
was from a tweet by I believe Chief nerd
which has been an excellent account uh
basically an aggregator that brings
together all kinds of interesting
information surrounding covet policy and
treatments
it's Nick Hudson uh uh he is
I believe he has taken the clip from
um from chiefner but anyway Nick Hudson
tweeted it but in any case what offit
says here is interesting because of it
who is a vaccine evangelist
acknowledges in fact he says there's no
doubt that there is a causal link
between myocarditis and pericarditis and
the covid vaccines
but then he goes on to explain what he
believes the mechanism is and he says
that it is likely because the spike
protein and mind you Dark Horse got fact
checked over the claim that the spike
protein was cytotoxic and that was
claimed to be misinformation though it
is clearly not misinformation
off it here blames the spike protein and
what he says is that it is likely that
because the spike protein mimics mimics
the heavy chain of the actin protein in
the heart cells when you create an
immunity to the spike protein you are
also creating an immunity that will
Target your own cells now on the one
hand
that is a major admission yep right sure
is some of us tried to warn about
autoimmunities about heart damage about
many different components and we were
ridiculed we were we had our sensor
demonetized
true facts yes and notice let's say that
his story is right that that's what's
going on here
well guess what those of us who said you
don't know the long-term effects of
these shots they couldn't possibly be
safe
we couldn't possibly have been writer
right what this says is there was no way
to shortcut this safety process and get
the benefit of it because what you
needed to see was what pathologies
developed down the road and you haven't
had enough time to see those pathologies
so that is a complete Vindication of the
idea that they had no right to tell us
that these things were safe because
long-term harms were unknowable at the
time to anyone
okay
but why is a vaccine Advocate whose
conflicts of interest have been raised
by many why is he making this
acknowledgment all right it seems like a
big acknowledgment but I would argue
that this is actually
the medical equivalent of a limited
hangout
meaning Define limited limited hangout
is a term in um
uh Security State and Espionage circles
for a presentation that minimizes a
particular set of facts does report
something true but minimizes the
significance of it so that it will sort
of satisfy the desire to know that
something bad happened you know it
throws somebody under the bus or some
process under the bus while rescuing
some core element and it allows those
who are who have been suspicious of the
claims to say see they acknowledge the
thing they're not they're not the bad
guys right no okay and we're and this is
going to be a big theme for today's
podcast but
um
the issue here I believe
why did all of the skullduggery that
unfolded around these vaccines happen
everything from the uh
the false demonization of repurposed
drugs uh to the claim that things were
safe and effective that couldn't
possibly be to the statistical
skullduggery that we will get to soon
why did all of this happen
well this is a hypothesis and I've said
it before but the hypothesis is that
Pharma which is a very difficult
business it is hard to find things that
actually improve human health and that
actually fight disease it can take
decades to get it done from the point
that you have something promising to the
point that you have something that has
been demonstrated to work and to be
worth the harm that it does in all drugs
do some harm
um so that can be decades out so that's
a very hard profile and it cannot work
you can invest hundreds of millions of
dollars billions of dollars in something
and then get nothing back it's risky
so okay that's the situation
Pharma adds something that was
potentially
radically changing of what is medically
possible it had the solution to a
problem that was very difficult to solve
and the problem that was very difficult
to solve was
many places you want a cell to produce
something it's capable of producing but
the genome doesn't support it either
because there's a broken Gene in the
genome that isn't producing the right
product or because the genome doesn't
contain the code at all and so you want
the cells to do something
in principle you could edit it in but
how the hell do you get enough cells
edited to make a difference right if you
can't produce insulin how do you get
enough cells to take up the gene that
would allow them to produce insulin to
solve your own problem internally
in the MRNA platform is brilliant right
it bypasses the nuclear genome and it
inserts the MRNA message into the
cytoplasm where the cells do what
they're told and they transcribe it and
they make any protein you want that is a
brilliant mechanism for solving this
problem but it has a giant gaping flaw
in it which is
any cell of yours that produces a
foreign protein which is what inherently
will happen when an mRNA message is
introduced into your cell will be
targeted by your own immune system and
destroyed you will create an autoimmune
disorder that's what it will do when it
works
how the hell are you going to bring such
a thing to Market well you would need a
solution to the following problem
how do you get it to only those cells
where that's a cost worth pay how do you
keep it out of your heart for example
while you can't do it by coating it in a
lipid nanoparticle that's just simply a
fat attracted to other fats because all
of your cells are covered in fat it's
completely indiscriminate right and
nobody can afford to have this happen in
their heart it's not the only tissue
where that's true but it's the most
obvious of them so they had a platform
that solved a huge problem and they had
no way to deliver it safely to Market
because they didn't have a targeting
mechanism what a shame
well
um I thought it was Rahm Emanuel who
said don't let any good crisis go to
waste I was recently told that it was
Henry Kissinger who first said that I
don't care which one it is I'd love to
know if Kissinger said it first but
nonetheless it sounds sounds like
something you might have thought
in any case
okay so they had a pandemic they had a
technology they couldn't bring safely to
Market and the emergency allowed them to
do it right the emergency allowed them
to go through emergency use
authorization to get people on board
with taking it because people were so
scared of covid it allowed them to
basically push aside all of the
safeguards that should have prevented a
prototype technology like this from
reaching the market without
demonstrating safety
well this might be um it's going to be a
big long diversion but this might be the
place to um share some from Clayton
Fox's newest piece
um because he talks some about the um
the creation of the eua in the wake of
excuse me in the wake of the um
mandatory Anthrax vaccines in the
military well let me let me come back to
it I'll just complete the what I think
is the offit story here so okay it's
Pharma accomplished the impossible it
took a technology that it owned that was
in my opinion at least three decades out
from being usefully and safely
Deployable if at all there's no telling
whether you could have rescued it but if
they've had a way to Target it it might
have taken three decades for them to
figure out what that way was to figure
out how to bring it about and then to
show that it was safe
and they didn't want to wait and so this
crisis gave them the opportunity not to
wait now here's the point now you've got
a huge fraction of the globe that has
already accepted mRNA vaccine technology
and how
are you gonna rescue it from a 1 in 35
chance of damaging your heart
right how are you going to overcome the
dawning awareness that this stuff is
lethally dangerous and to tissues you
cannot afford to have damaged
blame the spike protein right if the
problem is inherent to the spike protein
then okay we admit it we picked the
wrong protein but all you got to do is
swap in A protein that doesn't have some
flaw like this and the MRNA platform is
right back on track on the other hand if
we are right in what we have been saying
if it's both things if it's if it's both
which by protein is a bad choice and it
doesn't matter what protein any foreign
protein transcribed by your cells is
going to cause your own immune system to
go after your own heart cells if that's
where this thing ends up transfecting
yes so then is both a hundred percent is
both well let's just say well okay you
know logically stopped that was a figure
of speech I should not say 100 in a
scientific context but uh is the spike
protein cytotoxic yes now we even have
Paul uh off it what did you call him in
a vaccine evangelist
acknowledging that and is the MRNA
platform itself going to
indiscriminately because it has shaved
away all of the evolutionary
context of the organism that is
supposedly vaccinating you against
indiscriminately attack things like your
heart cells yes do I know that 100 no
but it seems extraordinarily likely that
both things are true and we have
evidence in both cases and the yes much
evidence of many kinds has emerged since
we first deployed that hypothesis right
that there is evidence of immune cells
attacking the heart where we have these
cases of myocarditis it's not simple
inflammation it is tissue destruction
that is Downstream of transfection of
these cells and even worse this platform
involves hyper stabilized mrnas that
when the cells that contain these
transfection elements are destroyed
spill out and are liable to transfect
new cells they and transfect immune
cells in fact cells that are dedicated
to cleaning up the uh the destruction of
cells that the body assumed were virally
infected so
either we have a well that was an
unfortunate protein to have chosen we
should have picked something else you
know but mistakes happen which is what
Paul office claim is or this platform is
still fatally flawed and that's why it
never should have been sped through all
of the processes that would have been
necessary to demonstrate you had a
vaccine that was worth the cost of
injecting it in people so that's where
we are and I believe what Paul Offutt is
doing is a limited hangout designed to
rescue the MRNA platform from the
natural
um
consequences of what we have now
discovered at the cost of
who knows how many lives globally who
knows how many years people lost who
knows how much the cost of this
Destruction has been and yes the spike
protein was not a good choice as we have
said many times
but it is far from the worst problem
here and the worst problems do indict
this platform until proven otherwise
awesome I mean completely diabolically
terrible yes awesome yeah
um
uh so should we talk a little bit about
or or read some excerpts from uh the
tablet or a piece that Clayton Fox just
published
um let me just take some notes here for
a second
um
Spike protein okay so uh Clayton Fox
whom we've um we are now friends with
and we have talked um we've read some of
his work here before uh is publishing
regularly in tablet and tablet has
become just an amazing
um maybe it always was I have come to
understand it to be an amazing
publication
um not just
um because of what it is publishing of
of Clay's but here's a piece that came
out on
yesterday called thinning the ranks
using vaccines is a political weapon U.S
military leaders have wrecked the forces
combat Readiness and morale current and
former soldiers tell tablet and so
here's the pretty great um
image image that runs with the with the
piece and excuse me um I have some
excerpts highlighted that it's a long
piece I highly recommend it we'll link
to it in the show notes I highly
recommend the whole thing but uh sorry
I'm making people dizzy uh here's the
first excerpt from the military
standpoint the Mandate was not just a
matter of life and death but also of
national security so I should I should
say
um
they're talking specifically about
military vaccine mandates which you also
had a conversation and actually he cites
he cites your conversation on Dark Horse
in was it like October or November of
last year October 22. I had two your
conversations with a total of six or
seven
um uh former and I think it was five and
then uh an attorney associated with
their their claim uh um uh people in the
active members of the military yep yeah
so from the military standpoint the
Mandate was not just a matter of life
and death but also of National Security
if infections swept to the ranks due to
troops refusing to take available
vaccines Not only would that destroy
morale and discipline but it could also
leave the country unable to respond to
an attack or emergency
the problem with this argument is
twofold first covid-19 never posed a
significant acute risk to healthy young
people the very demographic that
overwhelmingly makes up the military
which means the vaccination Drive was at
best unnecessary
secondly according to several sources
the military's approached the vaccines
rather than emphasizing combat Readiness
was used as a disciplinary tool to
enforce political Conformity and punish
independent thought and ideological
dissent
it's an important sentence right there
I've seen everything from don't ask
don't tell repeal to gay marriage
legalized people are allowed to put gay
pride Flags in their offices now said a
member of an elite infantry unit with
over a decade of service the jarring
thing he explained was that the same
military that boasts about its tolerance
became rigidly intolerant on the
question of bodily autonomy and vaccines
quote you can get exemptions for
religious beards if you're Muslim you
can get exemption to wear headgear
instead of your issued hat that's fine
I'm all for it if you can do the job you
should be allowed to do it but then for
a vaccine that's violating the Nuremberg
code and all of a sudden we're the
problem that's what's bizarre to me
many of those who refuse the vaccines
did so on the grounds of the Band-Aid
violated the Nuremberg code of ethics
for permissible medical experiments the
first line of the code reads quote the
voluntary concept of the human subject
is absolutely essential
though signing the code point out that
these coveted vaccines had not even
finished their clinical trials of the
time troops were being pressured and or
mandated to take them and were therefore
being asked to sacrifice their
nuremberg-derived rights Health
authorities in the U.S dismissed that
claim on the grounds that the vaccines
had received Emergency Operations
authorizations and were therefore not
strictly experimental
I don't know if you want to add
something there or I should go to the
next excerpt yeah I do want to add
something okay uh it's a general comment
about you know obviously since I had
covered this story some of this wasn't
new to me on the other hand there was
the story is quite exhaustive and
what it revealed to me was that what we
saw informally play out in the wider
world right The Bullying that took place
over people's justifiable skepticism of
new so-called vaccine Technologies
that that played out in the military in
a very different way because of the
formalized uh
hierarchy right the military requires a
formalized hierarchy which means that
essentially everybody except the lowest
rank was in a position to boss somebody
else around and so to the extent that
you were formally empowered to do this
people took on a kind of uh you know
Cinema uh
drill sergeant approach to getting the
people below them in line yeah and this
is so diabolical in in a case where
people had just a normal right to feel
caution about a technology that was
brand new that they were being told that
they needed for a disease that was not
killing people in their circles this you
know it's not killing healthy young
people right and
that right vanished and then the other
thing is
and I wish the piece hit this note
harder
the fact that by purging people by
driving them out making their lives a
living hell and then formally purging
them from the ranks if they refused at
the point that the mandates uh became
viable
we have created a force that is now
compliant
right a military force that will now
accept immoral orders including
violations of a code that was produced
at no small cost in U.S military lives
yes fully aside from the medical
implications and autonomy implications
and personal health implications
the mandates were a selective force that
has created a compliant
military
and we need
because of what the military is because
of the of the need for hierarchy there
needs to be compliance
within reason which is to say there
needs to be compliance and reason every
single soldier needs to do what they are
told in times of duress and also needs
to be keeping their brain alive and
thinking you know what
not that order
no sir
not that order they need we need a force
that that can and does and will stand up
to unethical orders when they come and
what we have had here is a selective
force a selective pressure to create a
compliant force that will not now the
the Beast does say and I have a few more
excerpts including one extended excerpt
here to to read does say that many
people
um in some in some units um the
estimation is a majority of people who
ended up vaccinated were resistant
um feel that they were duped
um I felt that they had no choice
because they needed to support their
families and were never pleased about it
so
um I you know that that provides hope
right uh that it's not that uh people
did the thing and went like oh wow being
compliant feels great I feel terrific
I'm gonna go about my day now like no I
think in some ways actually you may have
people who now have more reticence to
unethical orders than they did before
but who are still in the military I hope
well but I think it's at least a
possibility yeah I agree that that's a
possibility I think people are wide
awake in a way that um these Maniacs who
built this policy did not anticipate and
I think in large measure that happened
because a small number of channels that
they did not control including this one
uh were able to reveal that their
narrative was gone
but so what we can say is what were they
trying to do
I don't know if they were trying to
create a compliant Force but it's
certainly interesting that they deployed
a policy that would have that as a
natural consequence right so you know
from the point of view of uh what
William Binney called the term key
totalitarian state you know you can't
have a turnkey totalitarian state if the
military is fighting for the freedom of
Americans uh including their rights
under Nuremberg right you have to do
something to make the force deaf to
Nuremberg and this would be something
you would do the fact that it didn't
work doesn't indicate anything about the
policy being less diabolical than it was
because it was quite diabolical yeah but
um it uh you know yes it did not work as
well as they might have liked
a little bit more from from Fox and
tablet this week the covid-19 Mandate
forms part of a pattern of vaccination
you want to share my screen here
the covid-19 Mandate forms part of a
pattern of vaccination controversies in
the US military in the first Gulf War
over 150 000 U.S troops were vaccinated
against the anthrax bacterium which
military brass feared might be used by
Saddam Hussein on American troops
parenthetically notably the United
States also sold saddam's spores and
technology that might have allowed Iraq
to produce weaponized anthrax
one problem with the anthrax vaccine was
that any expected weaponization of
Anthrax would come through an inhaled
exposure and the vaccine the military
mandated had only been tested in humans
against exposure through the skin
in spite of the fact that the anthrax
vaccine wasn't licensed for prevention
of disease via inhalation in 1998 the
dod pushed forward with a military-wide
mandate
subsequently a small group of soldiers
refused to take it with at least 500
eventually being thrown out of the
military along the way
many replaced a military prison for
their refusals
prior to the mandates in 1997 a new
section was added to title 10 of the U.S
code the consolidation and codification
of the general and permanent laws of the
United States requiring the Department
of Defense to inform soldiers anytime
they are being asked to take an
investigational drug the reasons why and
any possible side effects that might
arise as well as Garner consent for
administration
the only way for informed consent to be
waived is by a written waiver from the
president and only if it's deemed
necessary for National Security
this was reaffirmed in an executive
order signed by President Clinton in
1999. but the dod didn't consider the
anthrax vaccine investigational in spite
of it being used in an unauthorized
Manner and so they didn't feel the need
to get a waiver
in 2001 then Attorney General of
Connecticut Richard Blumenthal advocated
for the mandates to be thrown out due to
the lack of a presidential waiver and
concerns about quality control issues
and FDA violations and its Manufacturing
he wrote a letter to Secretary of
Secretary of Defense Donald Rumsfeld
arguing that quote in effect the
military is forcing its Personnel to
serve as human guinea pigs for an
unlicensed drug that has not been proven
to be safer effective end quote
Blumenthal now a Democratic senator has
taken a very different view of the
coveted vaccine in January 2021
Blumenthal told reporters quote we need
these vaccines to go in the arms of our
veterans and into the arms of all
Americans end quote tablet has reached
out to Senator blumenthal's office for
comment on why the unlicensed code
vaccines were different from the
unlicensed Anthrax vaccines we have
received no reply
the anthrax vaccine mandate this is the
last of this little section the anthrax
vaccine mandate was thrown out after six
years with the U.S District Court for
the District of Columbia issuing a
permanent injection in dove versus
Rumsfeld but the legal backlash spurred
the creation of an entirely new
designation within the FDA the emergency
use authorization
codified in the 2004 project bioshield
Act Congress created a pathway for the
FDA to authorize unapproved biologics
for emergency use in an imagined
bioterror attack
wasting no time the FDA granted the
anthrax vaccines and eua in January 2005
which then allowed the military to
resume Anthrax vaccinations though only
on a voluntary basis
by Year's End the FDA had given the
anthrax vaccine full licensure for use
against inhalational Anthrax and the
military mandates were back in force for
troops headed to Regions with a higher
risk of biological warfare
looking back Dale Saran a former Marine
Aviator and Jag who represented anthrax
vaccine refusers and who is now a civil
attorney told tablet that he believes
quote anthrax was the trial run
surround thinks that at least some of
what drove the push for covid-19
vaccines inside the military is simply
profit quote the biggest government
contractors have always been the
raytheons all of a sudden with the
biodefense thing Pfizer is like the
third largest defense contractor the
biotech pharmaceutical industry saw that
they could wedge their way in and get a
chunk of that fat Department of Defense
pipeline
so a couple of things that should be
added here one there is
substantial evidence that the anthrax
vaccination campaign is actually the
explanation for what was called Gulf War
syndrome right right so this was a
potentially a trial run here where uh
the initial case and I think the first
eua that was granted was granted for the
anthrax vaccine in this case so anyway
rather like
if you read the real Anthony fauci by
Robert Kennedy Jr you see that actually
there is a precursor case surrounding
AIDS in which a lot of the tropes were
deployed for the first time
um and you know it's basically a rerun
the coveted version is a rerun of many
things that we had already seen with
AIDS in many ways in the military the
anthrax vaccine campaign is uh a a
notable precursor of the same pattern
that surrounded covid yep
um so yeah completely
um shocking how this unfolded in the
military context especially in light of
what the military is needed to do I mean
they deployed a vaccine whose safety
they didn't know anything about or very
little
uh on a force that is necessary to
protect the Republic that's right
so one last thing I'm going to skip a
few of these but one last thing this
from um
a member of the military
there's been an agenda again in the fox
piece and tablet there's been an agenda
at play that does seem to be pushing a
focus on things that don't matter and
what should be a militarily focused
organization such as paying for the
surgeries of transgender members said
Larson
at the same time that the military is
restricting isolating saying you're
undeployable to unvaccinated soldiers
because you're medically unsafe because
you're not receiving an experimental
gene therapy that hasn't even been fully
tested that same organization is saying
they will pay for you to receive the
surgery and be stuck on these hormonal
therapies that do literally limit your
ability to be in isolated situations in
many ways he said referring to an army
policy issued in June 2021 a few months
before the vaccine mandate that the
service would pay for transgender
soldiers to receive home run therapy
mental health care and surgeries were
deemed necessary the fact that those two
things occur at the same time to me is
just evidence of an agenda at Play
and they are
exactly the opposite of one another in
terms of the kinds of arguments they are
making about what is necessary and what
is important for both uh
health and bodily autonomy and also for
military Readiness because and you know
this is uh the other this is we're
mostly talking about coveted vaccine
mandates here
um but to have the service member tied
together which I didn't I didn't know
that they were so close in time uh that
the military had said actually we're
gonna
um we're gonna allow we we are going to
provide
um the quote-unquote health care uh for
transgender members that includes mental
health care okay but also hormones and
surgeries which
put put aside for the moment whether or
not anyone should ever have those things
done to them but what they clearly do is
render you a person who is a medical
patient for life
if you do not maintain
uh depending on what the surgery was and
depending on what the hormonal
interventions are maintain uh continuous
medical activation of the Fallout from
those medical interventions in order to
reveal yourself as the trans human that
you think you are the transgendered
human that you think you are
things go very bad very quickly and so
the military is simultaneously saying
that they will support and fund such
interventions which make a force
inherently less ready because you can't
have such people in places where they
will not have constant access to health
care and forcing
interventions on people which we know
now and there was lots of evidence
before uh have
bad health effects and uh you know Fox
does finish this piece by saying um that
none of the none of the people that they
have that they interviewed for this
piece that he interviewed for this piece
have any Adverse Events from the
vaccines that they know
but that doesn't mean that they don't
exist one in 35 we're hearing yeah the
this is and I tried to raise this point
too which is
if you want a country in which
individual freedom is prioritized in the
way that it has traditionally been in
the U.S
you need
a strong
and that means masculine military the
idea that the military would voluntarily
play games military can just simply say
look
um if you are in some form of medical
transition you can't be in the military
because it's inconsistent right it's
it's simply incompatible with the
mission rather than coddling these
beliefs and confusing the role the
mission of the entity all right so I
think that's true but that's even that's
that's more in the weeds than than my
objection here no I but I you know what
it's not reasonable
to be having
um you know healthy breasts be chopped
off because you feel like they they
offend your sense of self I'm
um no it's that it's it's it's not it's
not a good idea but
presumably
a few months later the ramifications of
that
um are are not such that you are going
to be uh going to be needing Health Care
um to maintain that condition
um but the hormonal interventions and
the so-called bottom surgeries
don't aren't stable right they aren't
stable we need
we need a military full of people who
can be sent out with not much but a lot
of training and their own Ingenuity and
can be self-sufficient and can create
self-sufficiency
um for not just not just themselves but
you know for a bunch of self-sufficient
people that the whole group can be
self-sufficient and they can find what
they need and do what they need to do
and not fall apart if they don't have
the intervention of some you know hyper
modern technological thing that has
suddenly come on the market and is
everyone you know too many people's
favorite pastime no it's just it has it
has zero place in the military it's like
saying okay
I really I've always had this dream of
subbing Everest but I'm going to start
on you know cross-sex hormones and have
a really invasive surgery a little bit
before and I'm going to expect everyone
else in my team uh to make sure that I'm
okay well you know what no that you you
and your selfishness and that's the
shallow end of the pool don't have any
place on that mission
so I was going to say the feminizing of
the military the confusing of gender is
the shallow end here the medical
compromising that you're talking about
is the next phase the demoralizing of
the force over
threatening people's careers if they
refuse to take these shots and it's not
even that it's not even that you have to
leave the military and go to a new
career these people did not get
honorable discharges they were
threatened they got General discharges
which means that anybody who's looking
to hire them is going to wonder
what it is that they did wrong and so my
point is all of that is
obviously going to destroy morale in
this Force where morale is a central
piece of the weaponry and what I tried
to raise many months ago
um Robert Wright took me to task and we
had a little back and forth on Dark
Horse about it but my point was we have
enemies we have a corruption problem in
which people can buy policy changes that
serve their interests at the expense of
the interest of the American public
why on Earth do we think that so many
policy decisions that compromise the
morale the Readiness the ability to
recruit of this Force why do we think
that that was actually just error upon
error why is it not obvious that we
should be asking the question at least
hey all of these things make us less
capable of defending the Republic some
people don't want us to be able to
defend the Republic have we checked to
see whether or not they there was
influence exerted that caused us to do
so many stupid things to this essential
function
I'm reminded of our um
piece I wrote and we talked about here
and that actually put on some some Dark
Horse merchandise do not affirm do not
comply
right
um both the language of affirmation of
uh your child's preferred gender and
less so compliance because compliance
does have a negative connotation but
affirmation is certainly the word used
because it's this very positive
affirmation but that message needs to be
here or heard
that message needs to be heard by
everyone for sure but it's going to be
harder to hear and therefore even more
important for women to hear
because on average a well-known
well-replicated psychological conclusion
is that women are more agreeable which
is a term of Art and psychology right
that agreeableness as one of the Big
Five personality traits
um is is higher in women than in men and
that means less likely to argue less
likely to disagree more likely to go
along to get along
right and there are places for
agreeableness and there are places for
disagreeableness and like many of the
differences in sex between uh between
humans uh the the differences point to
the fact that both have their place and
that both are valuable but as we move
towards valorizing female typical ways
of being over male typical ways of being
across across domains
we are putting ourselves at risk because
the male typical ways of being also have
their place and at the point like this
is the most obvious place at the point
that we're doing that to our military
this should be extraordinarily obvious
right the military is historically
traditionally and entirely male place
um now many militaries have some female
members but it is never going to be the
military is never going to be a female
phenomenon nor should it be right it is
this is this is ridiculous right so
um your point about uh compliance about
increasing compliance in the military is
actually another kind of feminization
because compliance is itself a form of
agreeableness you're right and so this
is yet another way that we are
effectively feminizing our military and
uh we can we can talk all day long about
what kinds of Demands we would like to
see quote unquote masculinized or
feminized and in general I don't use
those terms but if we start with the
with the conclusion
again well replicated from psychology
that agreeableness is more common in
women than in men and that all of us
have some agreeable moments and all of
us have some disagreeable moments just
you know it's not necessary to go there
but if we start with that
um well-understood conclusion that
agreeableness is more common in women
than men and we also understand that the
military historically requires
um a hierarchy
and for um the everyone beneath everyone
else to actually follow orders but not
when they are unethical
what we don't have is an agreeable
military historically we have one that
or the one that recognizes uh hierarchy
and keeps its brain alive whereas
compliance agreeableness just for the
sake of agreeableness just for the sake
of not causing trouble is not what we
need in the military it's quite the
opposite actually it raises another
point that you have made uh you have
objected when people have said that men
are more competitive and you've pointed
out that men are differently competitive
I have written peer-reviewed articles on
this topic yes
and so uh your point has been that
female competition tends to be more
cryptic yes and the issue of a military
force in which men are empowered to push
each other around a bit to compete with
each other that that's part of the the
thing that makes the force work is now
shifting into a mode in which people are
cryptically bullying each other and
using powers in ways that they were not
designed in order to force others to
demonstrate compliance to a normal order
that that does sound more like the the
female mode of competition and not the
male one so you don't want whisper
campaigns driving what is done in the
military right right that is that is
completely dangerous you also want the
altercations that men will get into in
the military to be exposed to everyone
you want them to be out out in the open
so that also I mean just at the at the
most basic level if you do end up
deployed if you do an FC in combat you
know who's got what skills and you know
who's willing to go up against what and
when you absolutely can't have this
being cryptic you can't have cryptic
competition in a military environment
this makes no sense at all and that's
what we're doing no
um I I can speak to the male side of
this males pushing each other around
uh exposing each other's flaws this
kinds of stuff that men do when they are
gathered together those things are
character building and it doesn't mean
that they're all nice right but the
point is in the end when you are you
know in some sort of a a fire fight
you you know who you're in battle with
and you know what they're made of and
what they're made of is better than what
they walked through the door with
because you leveled them up you leveled
them up exactly
yes yeah
um
yeah we are just weird make it a mess of
things yes yes we are yes we are uh
okay did you want to
talk I know you're you're getting
somewhere ultimately but did you want to
talk a little bit about this uh this
Cheap Trick
oh yes we must talk about the Cheap
Trick okay uh so
um
before we get to uh
why do we call it the shoe trick so
um there's an article called The Very
Best of Cheap Trick based on the album
Cheap Trick the I don't know 1980s band
something like that something like that
um but this is about uh the statistical
Trek of excluding partially vaccinated
people from assessment of from the
assessment of vaccine efficacy so as to
Juke the stats which guarantees the
conclusion of efficacy we talked about
this
um
back in live stream 179 and June 21st of
this year in our episode science strong
and fragile and it's an analysis that we
talked about then done by these two guys
Martin Neal a professor of computer
science and statistics and Norman Fenton
whom you have had on Dark Horse uh
professor of risk Information Management
both of them are in the school of
electronic and electrical engineering
and computer science at Queen Mary
University of London
and they have one of their one actually
you've got that on the screen there Zach
um an early paragraph in this piece you
can scroll down if you want but I'm just
looking at it on my screen The Cheap
Trick is simple categorize those who are
vaccinated as unvaccinated up until some
arbitrarily defined time period after
vaccination takes place the time period
might be 7 14 or 21 days the supposed
justification for this practice being
that the benefits of the vaccine do not
accrue until it has had time to kick in
and before it becomes effective on day 7
14 or whatever the recipe is considered
to be unvaccinated
so
these authors Neil and Fenton have put
together what Zach is showing on the
screen this fantastic new compendium uh
which uh apparently you asked them as we
see on screen here recently Dark Horse
podcast covered the issue and shortly
after Brett Weinstein asked me if
there's a comprehensive list of studies
that had deliberately committed this
Cheap Trick so they've put together this
article which is fantastic they say our
first attempt to provide such a list it
contains a mix of observational other
studies that have employed The Cheap
Trick when assessing vaccine
Effectiveness for either infection
hospitalization or death
note that as well as numerous and
varying time periods of the trick might
be employed there are four ways in which
this kind of selection bias might take
place
miscategorized the vaccinator
categorizes on the vaccinator
categorized as unvaccinated or twice
vaccinated categorize a single
vaccinated Etc
unverified those who are vaccinated but
cannot be verified as such or
categorized as unvaccinated
excluded those who are vaccinated but
are infected before 14 days or whatever
are okay to neither the unvaccinated nor
vaccinated categories but Aaron said
simply removed from the analysis
and undefined the definitions of
vaccinating unvaccinated are left
intentionally undefined
uh and that exclusion has as that
exclusion version of what they're
calling the Cheap Trick has tended to be
overlooked uh so you we're not going to
go through all of these but it's a it's
a remarkable list and if you want to
just scroll
um scroll quickly through these we've
got a New England Journal of Medicine
uh British BMC is British uh
I don't know I don't remember what BMS I
don't remember what BMC is infection
diseases Jama uh Lancet open form
infections uh the general vaccine again
Lancet and for each of these they
specify hold on just slow down a second
so there's bmj British medical journal
and and nature
and and here we have Neil and Fenton
um saying with regard to each of these
what it is that the Cheap Trick that was
clearly deployed in the study was New
England Journal of Medicine nature
Lancet vaccines uh and and on and on and
on and on and on we've got the cdc's
official definition we've got our
official report from uh various uh
Public Health authorities more with Jama
New England Journal of Medicine nature
Lancet wow those are some and those are
major journals these are and of course
they're major journals because it is it
is those papers and the fact that
there's more than one of them and in
fact many of them that have been the
basis for the argument
um that these vaccines are not just safe
and effective but it is your moral
obligation to take them because they are
just that freaking good and look at all
the card Artistry look at it so a
reminder for people who maybe didn't see
our initial analysis the degree to which
this simple misfiling of people
or ushering them out of the data set
entirely when they show up in An
Inconvenient place can create an
impression of overwhelming efficiency I
think if the delay was two weeks you get
an impression of efficacy at 85 or was
83 something like that it's an
impressive capability and it can do this
for something that has no effect
whatsoever right right if we decided
that tapping your nose three times was
the treatment and then we decided it
took two weeks to take full effect and
then we ran the study you would find 80
whatever uh percent Effectiveness based
on simply this categorization scheme so
here's what I want people to get from
this
when somebody speaks about peer review
as if peer review guarantees a certain
level of quality
what in the Earthly [__] are they
talking about if it didn't catch this
list of people making a simple error
that creates a statistical artifact that
leads you to believe an ineffective drug
is highly effective if they didn't catch
that
what did they catch
nothing just couldn't covet right
ultimately they caught covet we know
that but for God's sake this is it's not
one study that made an error no right it
is well I mean and it it reveals
almost certainly that's not an error
right that's it but the point is you
would imagine so at what level does your
system have to be broken that these
things are repeatedly submitted the
journal goes through some very serious
process called peer review sending it
out to people who are expert and who
scrutinize it because that is their
scientific Duty who didn't [__] catch
this like
there is no peer review right the point
is peer review is a uh it is it is
exactly like the rating agencies that
stamped the garbage uh uh financial
instruments that contained all of the
bad uh mortgages during the subprime
crisis as AAA right it's exactly that
[__] it is it's exactly that
um so anyway like seriously every time
you hear the word peer review think
about this list of papers in which this
insane error that creates a totally
fictional impression of efficacy just
pass through peer review and nobody
noticed
right
it
there is no peer review
and that is no incredibly long and
diverse list of all of the top
Publications that's not it's not like
yeah and I think not every single one of
those is peer review but the list that
have been there's some agencies like the
cdc's definitions right uh and second
and there's a pre-print in there but but
here's the question okay let's say that
um Martin Neal and Norman Fenton are
just that good in this mathematical uh
trick which is obvious in retrospect at
the very least and it was utterly
invisible to everyone until these
awesome uh risk analysts and professors
realize the problem yes so here's what
we're going to do we're going to start a
clock today I think they've just
published this list in the last week
we'll start it at their publication and
we'll see how long it takes for all of
the papers that made this mistake to be
retracted or corrected okay yeah yeah I
don't hold your breath I'm betting the
Earth ends first
that's what I'm betting yeah yeah okay
so that clock is now going
yep yep all right all right Doomsday
Clock
okay all of which was in some service of
of a story you wanted to tell yes I am
going to try to switch gears and see if
um there's some other way to make points
other than just simply saying what's in
those points and describing why those
points are true and things like that so
I'm going to try my hand at a parable
I'll see we'll see how this goes
um
we'll see how it goes all right so the
parable is about a
Frontier town the town of Marksville
the town of Marksville is uh in the uh
it's in the Idaho Panhandle is it yeah
it's a town it's so small it has one
horse and no Bank
okay until one day
Stagecoach pulls into Marksville and
from the stagecoach emerges a Mr fousey
fousey Mr faucy I see Mr faucy is an
impressive man despite being only four
foot three
and um
he uh he certainly speaks with a a set
of affectations that are characteristic
of a well-educated man from the
Northeast he sort of sounds like like
this he sounds like uh senator
with all due respect you do not know
what you are talking about
that's how he sounds so it's sort of
like uh it's like John F Kennedy but
without the uh the authenticity
um
it's that
um okay so Mr faucy uh gets off the
stagecoach
and he uh he announces his intention
to uh to set up a bank
first Pharma in fact is the name of the
bank first Pharma is setting up a bank
in Marksville and uh he
he describes the need for a team a team
of men to build the bank he needs men
who are willing to work hard long hours
he will pay them three dollars a day
which is a lot uh and they will be paid
in full once the bank is set up and uh
has the cash on hand
of course with that amount of money at
stake lots of men show up ready to do
the work he goes to the lumber yard and
he opens a a line of credit and he
begins to Source all the materials the
men work long into the night a week
later the bank
has been erected and another Stagecoach
arrives and from that Stagecoach all of
the necessary equipment and supplies for
a fully functional bank is brought into
the building and the bank is um
is uh is open for business and Mr faucy
announced
that um
[Laughter]
because he's in a town where you know
Marksville is you know it's not full of
fools these people are suspicious of uh
of people coming from the outside
Outsiders Drifters and all that and so
anyway they look uh Mr fousey with a
certain skepticism I mean he says that
um
what he's going to do is for anyone in
the town who puts their savings into the
bank
not only will their savings be secure in
his institution much more so than it
would be in their mattress or buried in
the backyard
um but he is also going to give with
every new account
free toaster
not just any toaster though yeah a
toaster a bank it's a bank they're
giving you a toaster for opening it it's
what banks do
um okay so but it's not just any toaster
right
certainly not it's an ivermectron which
is the uh it it's a good it's the Dark
Horse of kitchen appliances the
ivermectron toaster and this
um actually persuades a few people who
upon hearing that they're going to get a
toaster if they will just simply put
their money in the bank and leave it
there for a month they will get their
toaster
so a few people at first start
depositing their money and as others
watch the folks who have been persuaded
by this offer deposit their money they
think actually that'd be a pretty good
idea I don't want to be the last person
out here to have my money in my mattress
and I do want one of those ivermectron
toasters
um and so the townspeople begin to
deposit their money and uh business
picks up
three straight days from open in the
morning to close at night nothing but
deposits until every last person in
Marksville has deposited their savings
into the bank
they all feel a great deal of relief
until the next morning
the next morning they awake to a rather
unpleasant discovery
the bank isn't open there's no sign of
life it is shuttered and a quick check
around the back reveals
the door wide open
and uh
Samuel Harrisburg is the first towns
person to enter the bank and to discover
it has been
completely stripped of everything there
is
none of the equipment necessary for
banking there is no evidence of Mr
fousey
and uh Samuel Harrisburg walks through
the bank and he opens the front door
where the townspeople have gathered and
uh they stream into the bank to start
wrapping their minds around what has uh
what has happened
um
and uh Alexa karenson
upon seeing the bank stripped leaps onto
the teller's counter and he says
it was a scam
they've taken all their money they lied
about everything
and at that moment
Lenny brassade burst through the saloon
doors I don't know why the bank had
saloon doors in retrospect the people in
the town should have taken that as a
sign something wasn't right but the bank
definitely had saloon doors and uh Lenny
brassod burst through the saloon doors
into the bank
and he comes in uh with uh the dog on
zelish
I think I am now borrowing from Norm
Macdonald
um
apologies to Norm Macdonald if you're up
there I'm sorry unless you're digging
this in which case I'm less sorry but in
any case uh Lenny brassod strolls in
with the dog uh on zelish wearing the
medical scrubs sure and um
the dog stands on the hind legs and he
summons all of the wisdom he has gained
through the training and he says
but are we still getting our posters
at which point a uh Alexander Scott the
pastor of the local rationalist church
says
ah
don't be stupid
of course we're getting our toasters why
would they lie about that at which point
all of the people in Mocksville nod
their heads affirmatively
end of parable
my God yes
um
I will say
before before you get to your comment I
realized that I have left
hanging the question of whether or not
the townspeople got their toasters I
will perhaps revisit the question next
week
um so you'll until then I'm sorry it's
just a classic Cliffhanger maybe they
get their toasters or maybe they don't
why would they lie about
why would they lie about that
no I mean Parable taken point taken uh I
I'm not totally sure what Samuel
harrisburg's role in the town or the
parable is
um but
well you know that he doesn't have a
speaking part
no it doesn't even invite everyone or I
just he just he opens the the main doors
exposing the saloon doors inside of the
bank
all right well
um I'm sorry I don't I uh you know often
after I've seen a performance and you
know people are like hey what do you
think like you'd have to give me some
time I'd rather not talk about it right
away I just thought I'd like to like to
have it percolate and I don't want to
just right I don't know what I think yet
Brett well you don't know if they're
getting their toasters that's why
um now I do actually no if they're
getting their toasters that much I know
do you
yeah all right well yeah I don't but I
haven't written that part yet but um but
I will
soon
yeah
um
maybe that's it
yeah
I've apparently stunned you yeah no no
you have I guess I I think I I think I
will uh maybe I'll talk about music next
time and uh maybe that maybe that is it
all right maybe that's it that was that
was that was awesome
um
yeah that was awesome I don't know what
to say
we will have another great guest episode
coming up on Saturday yes right and
um
and make sure to tune into that uh we
forgot to say at the top of this hour
which is a mistake that uh you can now
join a watch party anytime we do live
streams at our locals uh which you can
get to by on Rumble I think it's a join
now button something like that uh and um
and we encourage you to go there we're
also going to as of August be doing our
private monthly q a through locals so
please consider joining us there
check out Natural Selections where I
write
um almost weekly I did not I did not
post anything this week in part because
I'm I'm working on a I'm working on
something else which I will talk a
little bit about next week as well uh
hey check out our store at
darkhorsestore.org where we have thing
lots of lots of lots of cool merchandise
uh printed and and manned and will
manned by a lovely couple right here in
the United States including that do not
affirm do not comply merch which I think
um well unfortunately it's never going
to go out of style because
have you been ever
we of course have our book
hunter-gatherer's guide to 21st century
available everywhere including signed
copies right here on the islands where
we live on Orcas at darville's uh which
you can also um find online
and
um and we have our patreons we are we're
moving people as much as possible
encouraging people to go to locals but
we still have our patreons open and
there are some things that happen there
that don't happen anywhere else
um so you can you can join us there the
Discord server is available on our
patreons and as soon it'll be available
on on locals and there you can join
karaoke happy hour book clubs lots of
great stuff lots of great people and
of course uh again check out our
wonderful sponsors this week which were
I've forgotten already what you read
seed and biome which makes a
non-toothpaste identifrus which protects
you from The Scourge that is dropping
your toothpaste in your sink Brett and
also paleo Valley with fantastic
products like
like their golden milk and I've now lost
where I was there we go we are supported
by you please consider subscribing to
our Rumble Channel joining locals also
subscribing to YouTube clips Channel all
of that sharing anything that you find
interesting relevant surprising shocking
all of that uh we we benefit from that
and we appreciate your support
until we see you next time be good to
the ones you love eat good food and get
outside and demand toaster truth
why not